Who knows the heart of the sea,
who knows its depths.
And as I read that,
I wondered to myself,
are we just the little fishes
abandoning ourselves to
the waves to sing and dance
and play?
Is that what we're doing?
And I'm not saying don't have fun,
I'm not saying don't
sing and dance and play.
Enjoy life of course,
and relish the joy of life.
But I think you have to make sure
you don't dance your life away.
Don't be one of the little fishes.
And in Docauto that final writing
of Masashi before he died,
the last thing he wrote
was never stray from the way.
And I think that that's
what this is about.
All the fun and the singing and the
dancing and whole the play. It's okay,
it's good.
But all those things,
yeah,
can be distractions
because there is a path,
there is a way
and you know what that way is,
you know what you should be doing.
And it's hard to stay on that path
because it is the path of discipline
and discomfort,
but it is the right path.
And did you know that?
And it is that path that will ultimately
lead you to where you really want to be
so that you can live
and you can die
without regrets.
I think a lot of times
people are trying to find the path,
then they're looking all around
different places and different people in
different influences. But man,
I think so often that path,
you know what the path is and people
know what they're supposed to be doing,
but they just don't get on
the path and stay on the path.
Yeah, I agree. Where it's something
they felt when they were eight or 12,
and they say they travel the world or
travel through life's experiences trying
to find the answer that was in
front of them the entire time.
And so they come back to see what they
knew with different eyes and to recognize
that they knew the path all along,
which is something that,
uh, I so enjoyed about this
book and the character,
both real and certainly presented
by the author of Musashi,
who is using his experiences in this
domain of the sword as a means of thematic
interconnectedness. And
so unlike [inaudible], uh,
called Udall at the end,
he is not just a
technician with the sword,
although he is a brilliant technician.
He's tilling the soil,
he's constructing buildings,
which later he did quite a lot of,
uh,
in terms of architecture and overseeing
the building instead of destruction of
things and finding at the highest
levels of performance with the sword in
felling opponents, the, the principles,
the first principles that
he can apply everywhere.
And that's part of what fascinates me so
much about Musashi or anyone who's the
best at what they do is that it could
be anything, it could be pottery,
it could be sniping,
it could be calligraphy,
but like the best they see the depth,
they see the,
the interwoven web that can expand from
that one fine focus into everything that
they do.
And I think that for me
at least is the path,
and maybe it's just coming off of a silent
retreat that I want to talk this way,
but it doesn't strike me as something
that is cleanly expressed in an Instagram
post or a quote necessarily.
It's more of a feeling like you know,
if you're sober and take a moment to
sit in the stillness in that stillness.
I don't mean sitting on a mountain top.
It could just be
five minutes of silence when you first
get up in the morning and observe your
own mind and how you feel like you know
if you're on the path or not or at,
you know when you're not
totally agree, you know,
you know when you're not on it.
And I think that the feeling of
being on it when you're on the path,
it has that beauty of
mindlessness or no mind
is what they would say.
You can say zen, the state of no
mind, and it sounds like unconscious,
but it's different. It's not
unconscious, it's not subconscious.
It's something else where you feel that
you are exactly where you should be
doing exactly what you should be
doing and you're not planning,
you're just putting one foot in front of
the other on this path that you didn't
have to find because in a way the
path was seeking you the whole time.
And it's just a feeling. It's a
really, it's a feeling I think,
that everyone can have,
but they get so caught up,
we all get caught up.
I don't wanna speak for you to find you,
and I'll speak for myself.
It's easy to get caught up in
the noise and the shiny objects,
and just like the little fish
you were talking about earlier,
it's like what you see that lure
to recognize it as a lure
is sort of the first step.
And then to realize that when you
look past the lure, all right,
there's a lure 16 inches in front of you,
and then you're in an ocean that
has endless fathoms of depth.
What a journey.